hall h let's start there 6 000 people
you guys got this wild giant action
superhero movie comedy what's it feel
like to feel that energy in the room man
it's unreal it's it's it's electrifying
um i mean this is our first time back in
like two years so we didn't really know
what to expect but the fans went crazy
um i'm just i'm stoked to be here it's
amazing and i want to just kind of back
up a couple of minutes you guys were
just walking on the carpet doing some
pictures there came a boom box out and
there's no good photo shoot without some
music what happened there
it's the zachary levi special that's all
i can say wherever zach goes music goes
and it's it's the way it needs to be
yeah and speaking of music i literally
was just talking to jack about you guys
are both musically talented he lied to
me and told me you guys were in a band
what's the chance that we could we could
get you and uh asher to do something
together well we are in a band
uh no i wish that's a fantasy of mine
i'm so sorry i lied straight to the
press did it drop i know band e.t
breaking news
i just think he's pre-meditating it oh
you guys you guys could do some music
together at some point absolutely i love
jack like a brother i'm actually gonna
try and go to his show on the 29th y'all
should go out there um and see him but
uh yeah i'm totally down yeah we'll see
what the future holds
but i've seen all of the fast and the
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family tell me something about working
with zachary what would surprise the
fans at home what'd you learn from the
from the boss man he gives such great
advice any any and he's such a good
human like the humility that he has is
just it's unreal and i mean you learn
something new from him every single day
so many life lessons because he's done
it all so
and how about our our goddess on screen
and off screen lucy lou what was it like
working with her
lucy this is actually the first time
lucy lou and i have been on the same
walking ground
yeah we i didn't see her at all when we
were filming but she's absolutely
incredible love her like such a nice
human and she's amazing so dude
congratulations on this movie people are
going wild for it me included man it's
amazing i'm wet i'm waiting for the
spin-offs on the sequels to come i'll be
patiently counting the minutes i am
doing the same as well my friend